vimos que podemos representar el
movimiento de un oscilador armónico
simple en una gráfica de posición
horizontal que luce bastante bien y que
la amplitud de ese movimiento el máximo
desplazamiento de la posición de
equilibrio en esta gráfica esto se
representa el máximo desplazamiento de
la posición de equilibrio así y el
periodo que le lleva a todo este proceso
realizarse t mayúscula es el periodo
pues es el periodo en el que se lleva
todo este ciclo de pico a pico o de
mínimo a mínimo o de cualquier punto a
su punto análogo en ese ciclo este es el
período t y con una gráfica ya sea de
xenón o cosenos podemos representar
cualquier movimiento que queramos si
tenemos un oscilador con una mayor
amplitud podemos imaginar es ir a de
esto verticalmente el periodo sería el
mismo pero es tiraríamos la amplitud o
si tenemos algo con un periodo mayor
podemos imaginar que estiramos esto
horizontalmente dejando
amplitud igual o estirarla en ambas
direcciones para representar cualquier
oscilador que quieran lo que es bastante
genial sin embargo en muchas ocasiones
también van a necesitar la ecuación es
decir que ecuación describiría esta
gráfica bueno antes que nada a qué me
refiero con la ecuación de esta gráfica
esta gráfica representa la posición
horizontal x que significa que tanto
desplazamos a la masa de su posición de
equilibrio como una función del tiempo
así que queremos una función que nos
diga la posición de la masa como función
del tiempo cuál sería esta ecuación va a
ser una función porque vamos a
alimentarla con cualquier tiempo que
queramos y la función nos va a regresar
la posición de la masa en ese tiempo y
la gráfica de esta función nos va a
representar la posición de la masa en
cualquier momento del tiempo ya que esta
gráfica debe ser congruente con lo que
nos indica esta función y esta función
nos dice la pose
la masa en cualquier momento del tiempo
como será esta función será un coseno o
un seno esa es la primera opción seno o
coseno para saber cuál es me fijo en
cómo inicia cuando t es igual a 0 mi
gráfica comienza en el máximo por lo que
voy a elegir coseno ya que el coseno
inicia con un máximo y cuando digo que
comienza en un máximo es que si ustedes
recuerdan de sus clases de trigonometría
el coseno de 0 es igual a 1 y ya que
esto es lo más grande que puede llegar
el coseno el cose no solamente puede ser
tan grande como uno el coseno inicia con
un máximo cuando x es igual a 0 y esta
función de aquí comienza en un máximo
cuando t es igual a cero así que voy a
usar coseno pero lo tengo que agregar
algunos otros elementos el coseno solito
no me va a servir ya que el cose no sólo
puede ser tan grande como uno y esto de
acá tiene que ser tan grande como a
cualquier valor que tenga está
decir mi oscilador armónico simple no
siempre va a tener una amplitud de 1 por
lo que necesito aquí una variable que
represente la amplitud de este oscilador
armónico simple dado para hacer esto
menos abstracto digamos que yo estoy
jalando hacia atrás esta masa unos 20
centímetros o punto dos metros así que
la amplitud para cierto oscilador
armónico simple particular es de punto
dos metros de manera que esto lo puedo
representar aquí con punto dos metros
así que esto ni siquiera llega a uno si
yo dejara esto con el coseno solito esto
sólo podría llegar a un 1 lo cual es
mucho ya que el máximo de esto es punto
2 y sin duda ustedes ya se dieron cuenta
que puedo multiplicar mi coseno por la
amplitud cualquiera que ésta sea porque
entonces uno por la amplitud pues me va
a dar la amplitud lo que significa que
este x solo llega a ser tan grande como
a la amplitud que es exactamente lo que
queremos quiero que esto sea tan grande
como sea la amplitud de este movimiento
y nos falta algo más todavía no
terminamos y quizás digamos que aquí nos
falta poner el coseno de t ya que esto
es una función del tiempo queremos poner
el tiempo aquí y que esta función no se
entregue el valor de la posición es
decir que nos indique dónde está si está
en punto 2.1 puntos 0 45 o cualquier
cosa similar eso es lo que nos debe
entregar la función si ponemos t solita
no nos va a servir ya que ya que sabemos
que el coche no de cero va a ser igual a
1 cuando esté coseno sea igual a 1 otra
vez quiere decir que es 2 pi esto si
usamos radiales podríamos usar grados si
quisiéramos pero la mayoría de los
físicos maestros y profesores prefieren
usar radiales para este caso así que el
coseno de dos pies sería nuevamente
igual a 1 ya que es aquí cuando esta
función del coche no ha regresado a
donde comenzó
así que si algo rota con un ángulo de 2
pin va a llegar al punto de inicio otra
vez y se repite el ciclo lo que quiere
decir que esta función reinicia el ciclo
cada dos segundos ya que cuando te es
igual a cero la función es 1 y cuando te
es igual a 2 para la función vuelve a
ser 1 lo que significa que el periodo de
coseno de t es 2 espn pero el periodo de
la oscilación no necesariamente es 2 pi
a menos que tengamos un caso muy
especial el periodo es el que tenga que
ser digamos que resulta que nuestro
periodo es de 6 segundos para este caso
particular si esto es de 6 segundos no
queremos una función que se reinicie
cada vez que te es igual a 2 pi no
queremos una función que se reinicie a
los 2 segundos en este caso queremos una
función que se reinicie a los 6 segundos
como hacemos esto bueno pues no podemos
tener t aquí si ponemos t aquí
ya vimos que el periodo siempre va a ser
ya que es aquí cuando el coseno dt se
reinicia como vamos a hacer esto pues
vamos a ser listos quizá ustedes ya se
dieron cuenta de que podemos resolver
esto agregando una variable aquí ponemos
una variable o mega aquí y esta es la
multiplicamos por t y ahora puedo
ajustar esta omega a lo que yo quiera si
está o mega lago grande o pequeña pues
puedo ajustar el periodo de esta función
como yo quiera y si son curiosos pueden
darse cuenta que esta omega ya la hemos
usado antes y en efecto esta omega ya la
hemos usado antes como la velocidad
angular y recuerden que la velocidad
angular es del tate está entre delta t
la cantidad de cambio en el ángulo entre
la cantidad de cambio en el tiempo lo
que quizás piensen no es relevante aquí
ya que esta masa nada más se está
moviendo adelante y atrás esta masa no
está rotando en un círculo sino
largo podemos representar procesos
repetitivos o procesos cíclicos con un
círculo unitario
en otras palabras digamos que comenzamos
aquí jalamos la masa y en este punto nos
detuvimos aquí va a ser t igual a 0 en
el momento en el que voy a soltar esta
masa crecería justo aquí en mi círculo
unitario y después pasa por la posición
de equilibrio que sería a un cuarto del
ciclo es decir llegamos acá luego llega
a este otro extremo en donde se comprime
por completo el resorte y estaremos aquí
a mitad del ciclo y esto va a regresar a
la posición de equilibrio desde la otra
dirección lo cual está aquí y luego
llegamos al punto inicial por lo que
tendremos un ciclo completo y es así
como podemos representar procesos
cíclicos con un círculo unitario y es
así como esto tiene sentido
puede parecer abstracto pero realmente
es muy útil porque vean lo que podemos
hacer y pensamos bueno
siquiera podemos definir esto bueno un
ciclo en el círculo unitario es dos
radiales
si estamos usando radiales así que un
ciclo va a ser dos pi y cuánto tiempo
dura este ciclo pues yo sé que para un
oscilador armónico simple nosotros
definimos t como el periodo de un ciclo
así que tengo dos pi entre t y esto es
lo que vamos a poner como argumento del
coseno y resulta que esto funciona aún
cuando usamos nuestras ideas más
sencillas sobre la velocidad angular
poner dos pi entre el periodo nos da una
función que se reinicia exactamente
cuando queremos y quizá esto no nos
convence del todo y si ese es el caso no
los culpo a mí también me resultó
confuso veamos si yo tomo esta función y
en lugar de escribir omega
nosotros podemos poner omega es la
velocidad angular y a veces se le conoce
como la frecuencia angular así que las
personas pueden usar diferente
terminología aquí velocidad angular
angular y si tomamos esta velocidad
angular o frecuencia angular la ponemos
directamente aquí en lugar de omega y
después la multiplicamos por t y vamos a
ver qué sucede esto es genial así que lo
multiplicamos por t que es nuestra
variable de minúscula es la variable 2
pi entre t mayúscula es constante y la t
mayúscula el periodo va a ser diferente
para diferentes osciladores pero para
cierto oscilador armónico simple la t
mayúscula o el periodo es constante y
qué sucede ahora cuando t es igual a
cero todo lo de aquí va a ser igual a
cero gente podemos poner lo que
querramos en nuestra variable y en este
caso vamos a ponerla como cero el coseno
de cero me da 1 pero ahora qué sucede si
pasa todo un ciclo y como valor en mí te
pongo mi periodo mi te mayúscula sucede
que ésta
se va a cancelar con la tf de aquí abajo
y nos va a quedar 2 pi como argumento y
el coseno de 2 también va a ser 1 por lo
que esto va a completar un ciclo cada de
mayúscula cada periodo y es justo lo que
queremos no queremos algo que siempre
tenga 2 pi como periodo y ahora tenemos
una función en donde podemos poner
cualquiera que sea el periodo aquí abajo
de manera que cuando me t minúscula
tenga el valor del periodo t mayúscula
todo este argumento va a ser igual a 2
pi y al coseno se reinicia a sí mismo
por lo que tendremos una gráfica o una
función que nos da una gráfica que se
reinicien con nuestro periodo t
mayúscula que es exactamente lo que
queremos en otras palabras para hacer
esto menos abstracto
tomemos esto para nuestra función
particular para nuestros períodos y
amplitudes particulares así que yo puedo
decir que la gráfica que representa esto
o la función que representa esta gráfica
en lugar de la pone
punto 2 metros apenas me cabe así que
voy a poner las unidades abajo x el
coseno y recuerden que elegimos el
coseno porque es el que comienza en un
máximo y esta gráfica comienza en un
máximo si hubiera comenzado aquí abajo y
luego se fuera hacia arriba hubiera
elegido el seno ya que el seno comienza
en cero y dos pies entre el periodo
reemplazo la t mayúscula con el periodo
de esta función con el periodo de este
oscilador que es de seis segundos y la t
minúscula muchas veces las personas se
confunden y no saben qué poner en lugar
de la t minúscula aquí no hay que
reemplazarla ya que estamos definiendo
una función en términos del tiempo por
lo que nuestra t minúscula va a ser
nuestra variable
esta es la variable que tenemos aquí si
quisiera saber el valor de la posición
de mi masa a los nueve segundos aquí
pondría nueve segundos reales
a los cálculos de esta función usando
los 9 segundos aquí y voy a tener la
posición a los 9 segundos o si quisiera
la posición a los 12 puntos 0 5 segundos
o si quisiera la posición a los 12
puntos 25 segundos aquí pondría a mi 12
puntos 25 segundos en el lugar de la t
mayúscula realizaría los cálculos y
obtendría la posición de la masa a esos
12 puntos 25 segundos esto es para lo
que nos sirve la función y es para esto
para lo que nos sirve la función así
podemos representar el movimiento de un
oscilador armónico simple y me pueden
decir oye nos llevó mucho tiempo llegar
a esto siempre nos va a llevar tanto
tiempo no una vez que nos acostumbremos
a trabajar con esto nos va a resultar
bastante fácil vamos a deshacernos de
esto y se encuentran con esto en un
examen o tarea y les piden que hagan una
ecuación que describa a este oscilador
armónico simple es sencillo lo primero
que tienen que hacer es
y si van a usarse nuevo coseno y pueden
decir a ver no comienza en un máximo y
tampoco comienza en un 0 comienza hasta
aquí abajo en un mínimo está bien
comienza en un mínimo por lo que podemos
usar de nuevo el cose no así que x como
función del tiempo va a ser igual a cual
es la amplitud de aquí es 3 metros
nuestra amplitud es de 3 metros ya que
este es el desplazamiento máximo de la
posición de equilibrio ponemos 3 metros
y luego lo multiplicamos por el coseno
ya que comienza en un extremo ya sea en
un máximo o en un mínimo va a ser el
coste no de aquí pongo dos pi entre el
periodo y cuál es el periodo de esta
gráfica veo la gráfica y me pregunto
cuánto tiempo le lleva a reiniciar
comenzamos en un mínimo cuánto tiempo le
lleva a llegar al siguiente mínimo pues
4 segundos así que mi periodo es de 4
segundos 2 pi entre 4 segundos y pongo
mi t minúscula
aquí no pongo nada más dejo mi t
minúscula ya que éste es mi variable en
la que pondré lo que yo quiera para
calcular la posición esta es mi variable
t de la cual esta x es función pero aún
no termino esta sería una gráfica que
comienza aquí y baja así esta gráfica
comienza aquí abajo pero no se preocupen
multiplicamos esto por un signo negativo
y convertimos nuestro coseno en un
coseno negativo y el coseno negativo
comienza aquí tomen en cuenta que
nuestra amplitud sigue siendo 3 si les
preguntan cuál es la amplitud la
amplitud va a ser la magnitud del
desplazamiento o el máximo
desplazamiento que sigue siendo de 3
metros positivo aún cuando la gráfica
comienza aquí abajo simplemente
incluimos un negativo extra aquí
adelante que va acompañando al coseno
para que nos dé el coseno negativo
esta es nuestra función así que tengan
en mente y recuerden que si comienzan
aquí arriba van a usar coseno si
comienzan aquí abajo van a usar el cose
no negativo si comenzamos aquí y vamos
hacia arriba será seno y si comenzamos
aquí pero vamos hacia abajo será seno
negativo y es así como lucen estas
funciones en resumen podemos usar esta
ecuación para representar el movimiento
de un oscilador armónico simple el cual
siempre tendrá un más o menos la
amplitud por el coseno o el seno de dos
pi entre el periodo multiplicado por el
tiempo este dos pi entre el periodo
representa la frecuencia angular o
velocidad angular y vamos a elegir
coseno positivo si comenzamos en un
máximo coseno negativo si comenzamos en
un mínimo seno positivo si comenzamos en
el punto de equilibrio y va hacia arriba
o seno negativo si comenzamos en el
punto de equilibrio y va hacia abajo